[Musik]
es ist eine grausame vorstellung und ein
verdacht der immer wieder aufkommt
werden auch vergewaltigungen
systematisch als kriegswaffe in der
ukraine eingesetzt
nach gezielten tötungen folterungen
entführungen wird die liste begangener
kriegsverbrechen die russland zu last
gelegt werden immer länger
es sind hunderte von vergewaltigungs
fällen dokumentiert worden darunter
minderjährige mädchen kleine kinder und
sogar ein neugeborenes
ein land im krieg dass die welt
aufrütteln will und sich selbst dabei
angreifbar macht
[Musik]
das mit das ist eine kriegsstrategie der
russischen föderation zur vernichtung
des ukrainischen volkes
doch gibt es dafür beweise die
menschenrechtsbeauftragte ludmilla
denissow war wird entlassen wohl auch
weil sich ihre behauptungen bisher nicht
belegen ließen wir wollen uns selbst ein
bild machen mehrere wochen recherchieren
wir sprechen mit expertinnen und
experten mit ermittlerinnen und
angehörige der soldat hat gesagt gib uns
deine frau dann gehen wir
wir besuchen tatorte und erleben dies
schwierig ist gerade im fall der
vergewaltigungen ist beweise zu finden
viele der menschen wollen einfach nicht
darüber sprechen
wir beginnen unsere recherche in boveri
einer gegend östlich von kiew unsere
ukrainische kollegin alexandra den
ganzen krieg hier miterlebt sie erzählt
mir von einem fall der sie besonders
beschäftigt hat
der fall des russischen soldaten wie
teilen er ist der erste der wegen
vergewaltigung und mord in der ukraine
angeklagt wurde in abwesenheit wo er
sich befindet ist unbekannt
wir wollen mehr über diesen fall raus
finden irgendwo in dieser gegend soll
alles passiert sein
überall an den zäunen das gleiche bild
menschen und kinder auf russisch
ein zeichen eigentlich dass hier
zivilisten wohnen genützt hat es fehlen
trotzdem nichts die straßen wirken wie
verlassen ein paar ältere frauen vor
einem haus sie sind die einzigen die
geräte dort hinten im nachbarort habe
der soldat die frau vergewaltigt aber
auch hier habe es viele fälle gegeben ja
hier wurden massenhaft frauen
vergewaltigt sie waren zum teil fünf
zehn oder elf jahre alt es war der
absolute horror hier aber aus angst will
keiner reden aber
niemand will darüber reden
das haus das wir suchen liege am
waldrand erzählen uns die frau noch eine
abgebrannte ruine die an den horror
erinnert der hier passiert ist
mehrfach sollen michael r und ein
weiterer russischer soldat die frau hier
vergewaltigt haben ihren mann hätten sie
zuvor erschossen so die anklage erst als
die beiden völlig betrunken
eingeschlafen waren konnte die frau mit
ihrem kleinen sohn fliehen
[Musik]
ist das wirklich möglich fragen wir uns
dass soldaten unbemerkt von ihrer
einheit und ihren für sie
verantwortlichen kommandeuren morden und
vergewaltigen wir treffen einen der
nachbarn und fragen ihn wie er die
besatzer erlebt hat
[Musik]
die haben sich aufgeführt wie die bilder
waren 18 oder 22 und völlig besoffen
die haben sich wie kinder bindungen
die haben kartoffeln auf unseren zaun
gesteckt und darauf geballert
es sind schilderungen die wir so oder
ähnlich immer wieder hören bei unserer
recherche die soldaten seien extrem jung
gewesen häufig betrunken und oft aus dem
fernen osten russlands mittellos und
unausgebildete marodierende einheiten
gnadenlos von der russischen armee als
kanonenfutter eingesetzt
zurück in kiew recherchieren wir weiter
über den mutmaßlichen täter und finden
massenhaft informationen im netz wo
klinische aktivisten und aktivistinnen
haben sie ins internet gestellt so
wollen sie helfen mögliche
kriegsverbrechen aufzuklären
namen der eltern und der schwester namen
der brüder
aber es ist schon krass dass sie dass
sie das alles veröffentlichen ohne dass
erwin prozess gegeben haben aber es ist
den teams gesetzt kriegszustand und du
findest du auch nicht schlimm dass die
fotos veröffentlicht
für die kriegszeit
jeder fall
wir nehmen kontakt auf mit dem mann der
die bilder gepostet hat wo er sich
aufhält will uns mit alu makarov nicht
verraten irgendwo an der front
wie kommt ihr ein bisschen frost
check.de whatsapp facebook
sehr oft nutzen diese soldaten
messenger-dienste die weiber oder
telegramm aber der größte schatz für uns
ist es wenn wir die handys der toten
russen finden
auf den handys sind massenhaft fotos und
die haben meta daten die zeigen wann die
fotos gemacht wurden an welchen orten
die fotos gemacht wurden das sind
wertvolle informationen für uns
ein ganzes land also als ankläger und
ermittler und ich frage mich ob das die
wahrheitsfindung wirklich leichter macht
am nächsten tag eine sondereinheit der
polizei sie ermittelt zu
sexualverbrechen die von russischen
soldaten begangen wurden wir dürfen sie
begleiten sie fahren von ort zu ort
durch gegen denn die die russen besetzt
hatten versuchen rauszufinden was hier
passiert ist eine mühsame spurensuche
merken wir denn viele der opfer haben
das land längst verlassen
wir müssen jede information nehmen die
wir kriegen können oft beginnt das mit
einem gerücht oder informationen die wir
über das internet bekommt dann versuchen
wir diese information zu verifizieren
also zeugen zu finden oder das opfer
sich
das wichtigste sei vertrauen aufzubauen
erzählt uns die polizistin die meisten
würden nicht über das erlebte sprechen
wollen zu groß ist die angst die russen
könnten jeden moment zurückkommen
es gibt kein gefühl von sicherheit
vergewaltigungen sind immer traumatisch
auch in friedenszeiten aber da können
sich frauen an einen sicheren ort
flüchten an dem sie hilfe bekommen hier
wird das sicherheitsgefühl für lange
zeit nicht zurückkommen wollte schaaf
die meisten opfer würden sich wohl erst
nach dem krieg trauen über das erlebte
zu sprechen glaubt auch irina benedikt
über die generalstaatsanwältin kämpft
seit beginn des krieges für die
aufklärung russischer kriegsverbrechen
als wie sie bei einer pressekonferenz
nach zahlen zu vergewaltigungen fragen
hat sie eine klare botschaft für uns
zuschauer aus europa wir sind immer noch
mitten im krieg das vergewaltigen morden
und foltern von zivilisten dauert in den
besetzten gebieten immer noch an wenn
ihr also einfach nur zahlen hören wollt
kann ich die nicht liefern das sind sehr
ernste prozesse es ist sehr schwierig
sexuelle gewalttaten aufzuklären während
der krieg noch läuft
die generalstaatsanwältin berichtet uns
von einer leichenhalle mitten in ihrem
team dort würden wir einen eindruck
davon bekommen mit welchen
schwierigkeiten die ermittler kämpfen
müssen der geruch ist kaum zu ertragen
allein in der zeit in der wir auf den
gerichtsmediziner warten werden dutzende
kriegsopfer aus den optionsgeschäften
viele davon zivilisten
sergei liakhovich nimmt uns mit zeigt
uns den lkw in dem sie die toten
aufbewahren müssen es seien einfach zu
viele wir wollen von ihm wissen ob es
viele fälle sexueller gewalt unter den
opfern gebe aber auch der
gerichtsmediziner macht uns klar wie
schwierig es sei genau dafür beweise zu
finden
vergewaltigungen und folter hinterlassen
typische spuren wenn wir unter folter
verstehen dass den opfern in die knie
ellbogen oder die hände geschossen wurde
das hatten wir häufig vergewaltigung
kann ich dagegen nicht bestätigen sie
können sich vorstellen die
verwesungsprozess um nach der langen
zeit
viele der opfer hätten in massengräbern
gelegen sie seien oft bis zur
unkenntlichkeit entstellt für die
familien sei das vielleicht das
schlimmste dass sie niemals wirklich
erfahren würden was passiert ist
unsere spurensuche geht weiter denn nach
wie vor beschäftigt uns diese frage wie
groß die dimension der sexuellen gewalt
ist in diesem krieg und gibt es hinweise
dass sie von militärischen vorgesetzten
angeordnet wurde
ich treffe richard gere und fred
abrahams von human rights watch aus dem
osten der ukraine ist uns welches wille
zugeschaltet alle drei untersuchen für
die ngo seit jahren kriegsverbrechen
was ist dein gefühl für die systematik
dieser verbrechen
wie groß ist die dimension
was denkst du was ist dein gefühl
ich habe in kriegen gearbeitet in denen
vergewaltigung als kriegswaffe
eingesetzt wurden ich habe erst vor
kurzem die situation der jesiden
untersucht wo vergewaltigungen extensiv
als waffe eingesetzt wurden
ich glaube in diesem fall sind es eher
individuelle fälle von soldaten die
individuelle verbrechen begangen haben
es scheint mir kein systematisches ziel
der russischen armee zu sein
ukrainischer frauen zu vergewaltigen
sind es denn trotzdem kriegsverbrechen
diese einzelfälle von vergewaltigungen
sind trotzdem eindeutig kriegsverbrechen
und jeder einzelne fall sollte
untersucht und verfolgt werden
kriegsverbrechen also aber so zumindest
sehen es die ermittler von jungen rights
watch wohl keine systematische
kriegswaffe
eine juristische unterscheidung von der
wir uns fragen wie wichtig sie für die
opfer ist wir sind interessanter einem
kleinen ort im westen kies wir treffen
war ja sie führt uns in ihrem kleinen
hof frau bis vor kurzem hat sie hier mit
ihrer tochter deren mann und ihrem enkel
gewohnt jetzt ist sie ganz alleine
es tut mir leid das ist hier so aussieht
ich schaffe das allein nicht mehr es ist
einfach zu viel weil er erzählt uns wie
drei russische soldaten im märz gekommen
sein und mitten in der nacht an die tür
geschlagen hätten betrunken und mit
sturmgewehren im anschluss die soldaten
hätten ihren schwiegersohn aufgefordert
ihnen seine frau zu geben
er hat ihnen gesagt wenn ihr jemanden
volt der mit euch kommt dann bin ich das
aber ich gebe euch nicht meine frau dann
hat er sich umgedreht und gesagt okay
wenn ihr nicht wollt dann eben nicht
dann haben ihm die russen in den nacken
geschossen das blut überall
die männer hätten ihre tochter und zwei
weitere frauen aus dem ort mitgeschleppt
und sie vergewaltigt erzählt weil ihr
und dann etwas das wir kaum glauben
könnte der kommandeur war dabei sie
waren zu dritt zwei soldaten und ihr
kommando dort hinten ist das haus buse
die frauen hingebracht haben
dann führt uns war ja in den garten
zeigt uns den ort an dem sie ihrem
schwiegersohn begraben musste hier haben
wir ihn beerdigt unter der tanne
erst als die russen wegfahren konnte sie
ihn in ein richtiges grad liegen sie
zeigt uns bilder aus besseren zeiten von
ihrer tochter dem schwiegersohn gut im
enkel hier da sind sie überall mit dem
kleinen die tochter sei mit dem kind
nach österreich geflüchtet und dort in
therapeutischer behandlung so war ja
dass sie jemals hierher zurückkommen
wird glaubt sie nicht
sie hoffe erzählt uns war ja noch dass
sich die soldaten und irgendwann auch
die russische regierung für all das hier
verantworten müssen selbst wenn es für
ihr leben nichts mehr ändern wird
wir verabschieden uns und begreifen so
langsam wie viele zerstörte leben diese
russische brutalität zurücklassen wird
und dass die aufklärung wohl gerade erst
begonnen hat
[Musik]